[Music]
the national spirits which become
conscious of their essence in the shape
of a particular animal coalesce into a
single spirit
thus it is that the separate beautiful
national spirits unite into a single
pantheon the element inhabitation of
which is language
the pure intuition of itself as
universal humanity has in the actuality
of the national spirit this form the
national spirit combines with the others
with which it constitutes through nature
a single nation in a common undertaking
and for this task forms a collective
nation and there with a collective
heaven
this universality to which spirit in its
existence attains is however
only this first universality which first
issues from the individuality of the
ethical sphere which has not yet
overcome its immediacy has not yet
formed a single state out of its peoples
the ethical life of the actual national
spirit rests partly on the immediate
trust of the individuals in their nation
as a whole
partly on the direct share which all
regardless of differences of class take
in the decisions and actions of the
government
in the union which to begin with is not
a permanent arrangement but only for the
purpose of a common action
that freedom of participation by each
and all is for the time being put on one
side this first alliance is therefore
more an assembly of individualities than
their domination by an abstract thought
which would rob the individuals of their
self-conscious participation in the will
and deed of the state
paragraph
727 is the first in a new subsection and
this is a
third and final subsection of the second
section
of the religion portion of the work and
there's a lot going on here that we're
going to have to unpack but before we do
that i want to talk a little bit about
all these sections and how things fit in
with each other a little bit of
commentary
on that to give us a reminder of where
we are and how close we are
to the end of this long dialectical
journey through consciousness and
history that hegel calls the
phenomenology of spirit so let's back up
a little bit we are in this penultimate
section which is called religion
and this comes after
the you know the preface and the
introduction all that interesting
material then the rather abstract
consciousness section the more
concrete and richer
self-consciousness section in which the
key idea of recognition or
acknowledgement on air cannon takes
front and center as a value that's going
to be worked out through the rest then
we have this massive reason section an
even larger spirit section then we
finally come to a shorter section
religion which is
bringing together all of these previous
dialectics and going back over
some old ground but also introducing
some new things and here
hegel is once again talking primarily
about greece and perhaps by extension
rome as the ethical nation par
excellence because he is you know
essentially a pro-helen uh pro-greek
kind of person the way many of these
these germans were at that time but a
lot of the things that he's saying
could be extended to
other types of the word that he's going
to bring up here
pantheons right what is a pantheon it is
so it comes from greek
pan all and then theos
god or divinity and so this is the the
gonzai the totality
of the
greek gods actually not all of them
because as we've seen there are the you
know kethonian gods as well but we're
going to overlook that for for just a
moment and so we are
getting now
into something
that's going to be
really distinctively
connected to art but art in a different
way
than we've encountered so far what have
we been looking at so far
we could talk about primarily
visual and even tactile art
we began by looking at crystalline
shapes
and plants and animals
and the sun itself and all of these
nature things that then could be worked
into
forms gestalten by
at first a
craftsperson you know the varric meister
and then by the artist and we get the
statue we get the temple now we've got
architecture and then we we talked about
this entire
you know range of things that fit into
the cult the cultists in hegel's german
and there's a lot going on there we
talked about some
preliminary forms of language that play
an important role within that the oracle
the hymn
the
frenzied ravings of the you know uh
crowd that's that's inhabited by the god
filled with enthusiasm that's what
enthusiasm
literally means and then we in the last
paragraph we brought up this
new kind of use of language
not new necessarily
historically although i suppose you
could say that what we're going to talk
about here
is in fact historically coming later
as we'll see in just a moment when we
mention
these kinds of language
and
it's going to take on and now the
we could call it intelligibility
that it didn't have in the previous
paragraph in the last
subsection it was being
mentioned but not being
adequately explained it's not going to
be fully explained in this paragraph
either that's coming throughout this
entire sub section but
what are we talking about
poetry
and when we hear that word
poetry today
there's often a tendency to associate it
with the sort of things that we're more
familiar with like you know
little rhymes roses are red violets are
blue blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
right put whatever else you want in
there
things that we see in greeting cards yes
that's that's poetry sure or we
associate it with you know poetry slam
people getting up in front of a crowd in
a coffee house and having that poetic
diction that they use with it right
that's actually a little bit closer
to ancient poetry ancient poetry was
meter-based
it wasn't so much about rhyming things
it was about conveying
important ideas it wasn't
necessarily so much about your own ideas
as you expressing yourself in your place
and time
or your experiences although there was
lyric poetry for that right we have you
know um
you know sappho writing about love and
we have our kill arca locus and we have
all these other people writing writing
lyric poetry including solon right
writing about politics to some degree
but that's not what we're talking about
here either we're talking about other
genres
of poetry
that are conveying something
we could say
less individual less individuated less
sunk into its individuality
and more
universal as we're going to see in the
text here and as we're going to see in
the paragraphs
yet to come so when we're talking about
language spracha here what kind of
language do we actually mean well if you
read ahead
in this subsection which by the way i
strongly suggest you should be watching
these videos uh you know and that you
should not be hitting on this paragraph
for the first time you probably want to
read the whole uh subsection before you
you watch these
these uh commentaries
because then you have some idea where
you're going right
you're not just going along for the ride
um
first hegel is going to talk about epic
and we're going to discuss this in at
great length but we should say a little
bit about that in just a minute and then
where are we going after epic
tragedy
now with tragedy
we have no longer something that is just
recited or later on written down
we have something that is actually
performed
and involves more than one person as the
main speaker i mean with epic you could
have kind of call and response if you
wanted to
but it's still a main person who's being
translated here in the paragraphs to
come as a minstrel but we often say bard
right
or the storyteller the reciter with
tragedy we actually have plays and plays
involve a stage
and actors and a chorus and all these
other elements that
wind up being discussed by aristotle in
poetics the one book that we still have
of at book one
and then after that hegel is going to
discuss
the counterpart to tragedy which is
comedy
comedy is also drama comedy is also done
on a stage now of course you can do
comedy in other ways think about
stand-up where one person gets in front
of a mic and talks about you know
whatever is going on in their life you
know what's the deal about air airline
food or whatever other
silly stuff that they want to bring up
right but um comedic plays
were done on a stage like tragedies and
i mean there were other kinds of plays
as well the sadder plays
we don't actually have that much of
greek drama preserved as as we'd like
much the same with most ancient
literature but we have enough to have a
pretty solid idea about what was
going on
so those are going to be
the modes
of
language of discourse that hegel is
going to
devote attention to here and we could
say well what has that got to do with
religion
well
you know on a very basic level the gods
play some part
in epic actually a significant part
right if the epics that we have in mind
are the iliad and the odyssey the gods
are
characters and also determiners within
it
they also play some role sometimes in
the
tragic and even comedic works
so there's content
but there's also another important
feature
these things were done as ways of
relating to the gods i mean sometimes
people say silly things like homer was
the bible of you know the ancient greeks
and the bible doesn't actually make
sense to say that because top biblia is
a greek word that comes about later on
after we put these things together um
but it was held in a certain kind of
reverence these these works
so
it does make some sense to do that just
don't push that analogy too hard because
it'll fall apart very quickly
so that that's something we need to keep
in mind when we're seeing this
discussion of language or spracha
let's oh there's one other thing i would
like to mention before we turn to the
text
so this section is the spiritual work of
art right gestiga right and the previous
section was the living work of art and
before that we had the abstract work of
art now did hegel
pick those terms just willy nilly no
there's there's a point to it we go from
something that is more
static less
well articulated less
self-conscious although
self-consciousness is deeply involved
with it and trying to make its way
through it we go from something that's
abstract
to something that is living life
for hegel is something more than the
merely abstract or even you could say
there's a transition going on in nature
from the one to the other but life
by itself does not yet
have
a meaning or a questioning of meaning or
a attempt to reconcile these things life
reproduces itself life consumes life
enjoys
but life does not provide the kind of
focus and development
that
geist spirit mind provides and that is
something that is being worked out
through this medium
and notice what else he says
habitation
of language so let's now turn to the
text after having said all of that
one thing i want to point out right off
the bat
miller's translation
makes it a little bit tricky
at points to differentiate different
german
terms that are being used particularly
if we if we look at the previous
paragraph
in the pre the earlier subsection and
this paragraph right here
when hegel is talking about
national
spirits he's actually using two
different
terms there so one is
folk geister right so folk
is focus something that can be
translated as nation
you know it's like the greek ethnos
um it doesn't yet mean anything like
what we are going to talk about here a
state
but it does signify people that are
bound together by not just blood but
much more important by meaning by shared
history and narratives by uh
understanding each other by as we're
going to talk about in a moment trust as
well
so
folk
geister right
um that is one thing and then we have as
we just had earlier
uh
natsuna geister national spirit and here
hegel will talk not about that but about
a nation
a single nation einer nazion
um he'll also specify this as something
different than the state state right we
don't yet have a state but we do have a
nation and we do have
uh a folk
in in one sense and we have fukure the
plural of of folk um
in another sense there's a kind of
binding a kind of unifying going on here
there's really three main things
happening
in this paragraph we've got this initial
part where we're talking about the
development of a pantheon and this is
going to assume greater importance in
the paragraphs yet to come and then we
have this discussion about the nation
which is connected with
this and this is why it's part of the
religion section right the pantheon
represents
something that is happening with the
formation
of a nation and its ethical life and
then we have this
common action common project you might
say
and you know one great
prime example of this in epic that you
can think about
is the war against troy
right
that is an example of a uh gemini zamen
handlung as we're going to to see but we
could think of many others as well the
uh assembly of the greeks against the
persian empire very important for greek
consciousness and like i was saying
earlier we could apply this to other
pantheons and other
nations and ethnicities as well so
he says
the national spirits which become
conscious of their essence their vision
in the shape the gestalt of a particular
animal
coalesce
into a single
spirit
so we have a
plurality that are being united into one
thing and he says thus it is that the
separate
beautiful
national spirits
unite into a single pantheon a single
assembly of the gods a symbol a single
storyline we could say as well one
overarching narrative universe
the element and habitation
bahausen
of which is language
so we now we know what we're talking
about here in this new
important
use of language it is what allows us to
have this pantheon it is what allows us
to bring these different cults
together
and their
their gods
it's interesting that he uses the word
beautiful shona right
this is something that kind of
corresponds you could say to the greek
colon
beautiful fine noble
honorable something that is good in a
certain way right
and so all of these are being brought to
a kind of unity says
the pure intuition on xiang of itself as
now notice what he says here universal
humanity
universal humanity has in the actuality
the vehicle kite of the national spirit
this form
the national spirit
you know the folk geister
combines with the others with which it
constitutes through nature and here's
where we get this this other thing
a single nation
now
notice what else he says here
it's not enough just to have like well
you know we're a bunch of gods and um
we kind of need to like
pool our resources or you know uh maybe
we need to like get all on on on one you
know big
plan so we don't bump into each other or
something like that let's have a
pantheon
that's not how it actually
works here it's not just that the gods
decided this and then like revealed it
to humanity and they're like okay you've
been worshipping you know poseidon up to
this point that's good but you should
also have a temple for hera and a temple
for athena and a temple for apollo oh
you don't want to build all those well
you can go to delphi for apollo and
maybe worship there and get to get the
oracle to tell you that's not how it's
working
a single nation right
there's there's he also talks about a
collective nation gazant folk as we're
going to see a single nation einer
nazion
is being developed how
in a common undertaking
a common
project
common job something that motivates them
it could be external fighting against an
enemy who is invading
it could be
you know it could be the games that are
being held that unite
right it could also be going and beating
up those trojans for uh taking helen um
could be all sorts of things
and he says
for this task
forms
a collective nation
right
um
folk
so now it's no longer just
uh
you know folk it's gazantful a greater
totality
which also is correlated to a collective
heaven
gazant himmel and what is that
collective heaven
it is the location
both you know physical you look up at
the sky and maybe on mountain olympus or
something like that but also in
imagination and narrative um of the
pantheon of these these gods that are
now being connected with each other
so he says this universality to which
spirit in its existence attains now what
universality
universal humanity right everybody who
writes an epic
or who engages in this sort of pantheon
building
views themselves as the
model for humanity
others are like them but usually
deficient you know think about the
greeks and how they
have this kind of goldilocks formula oh
you know we're the greeks we have just
the right amount of thumbos not like
those crazy northern people you know uh
the the uh illyrians and and the celts
and all those those warlike people and
we're not like those supine slavish
egyptians or persians you know we've got
just the right amount
well that's that's pretty typical in the
way that that peoples frame things for
themselves so this universality to its
spirit in its existence attains is only
this first universality which first
issues
from the individuality of the ethical
sphere which has not yet overcome its
immediacy
not yet
formed a
state
out of its peoples so this is prior
to the state
and
you know there's still governance going
on they're still ruling you know regul
there we go
there's there's still
a common task probably a common enemy
that that's at play and so he says here
what do we have
ethical life
zi li kaite
right
following the mores developing the mores
further
expressing them
the ethical life of the actual
vehicle national spirit
rests and here he says two really
important things rest partly
tiles in in german
on the immediate trust
of the individuals in their nation as a
whole
and partly on the direct share which all
regardless of difference of class taken
the decisions and actions of the
government okay so this is this is
really
key and central
not only do we have a connection with
sort of you know the realm of ideas and
language and
representation going on here we also
have something that's happening
in the the nation that is coming
together as a single nation einer nazion
as a collective nation a gazant folk and
it's happening
on two bases we have the immediate trust
fairtrauen and that's something that we
have to unpack of individuals in their
nation
as a whole engants right as a totality
not as the only nation but as their
nation as their folk as their
ethnos
and this trust is not just sort of a
blind
you know
identification of oh well i'm an
athenian and athenian athenians are the
best and athens is so wonderful it's
it's not just
something like patriotism
you know in in its uh debased form
in order to be a people
you have to have
you could say trust or you could say
confidence
that
collective action is possible that
collective ways of looking at things
makes sense
that the language that you use is
actually going to be received we don't
think about this most of the time
but that's there
that's there in societies civilizations
nations states
across you know
things that unite us all like say the
internet
that trust is really an important
element here so that's one thing that's
going on
a direct share on tile
in what the actions the handling and the
decisions earth island
of the government of the ruling class
the ruling people the regul right and so
he says
regardless of difference of class or you
know occupation or whatever
this direct share which they take in in
the the actions and decisions of the
government and then he says in the union
which to begin with is not a permanent
arrangement like that of the state would
be right but only for the purpose of a
common action and han lung right
something that everybody wants to get
accomplished even though they may have
different ways of looking at it a great
example of this is you know in in the
iliad right we see conflicts between
people
about precisely what they ought to do
or how things ought to be done
it's not as if they're all in complete
unanimity about the means but there is
some sort of common
end and so he goes on and he says
in the union which is not a permanent
arrangement but only for the purpose of
a common action
that freedom of participation by all in
each is for the time being
put on one side
they have to have some organization
right they have to have war leaders
not everybody can
be the general and but he calls this
the first alliance
a long term
gemini shaft leak kite
a
being bound together
in something like
being part of the same
mine
the same
you know ethical community very often in
german mineshaft is is uh connected with
uh zitten right and then it's it's being
um contrasted to gazelleshaft which is a
more
you know thought out arrangement
something that that may have developed
historically but is closer to morality
in the hegelian sense
so he goes on and he says
this first alliance is
more an assembly of individualities
than their domination by an abstract
thought which would rob the individuals
of their self-conscious participation
in
now notice this the will villa that's
just will
and the deed tot
now he doesn't say of the state as
miller translates it here
rather it's the guns right of the
totality of the
the group you could say so state isn't
being brought up here but rather
what we have going on this common action
being guided by somebody running the
show
giving some sort of order to it but it's
not an ord nung it's not a rigid
for all times
self-consciously thought out ordering
and now we can say well okay so we've
come a long way
how do we get
from this stuff back to the pantheon
aren't we talking about the gods
well yes because the gods and this
language are going to
play a role
in this
common action
iliad's a great example the gods fight
on either side
as a matter of fact athena actually sets
up a hit on aphrodite by the human being
the hero diameters
uh who she you know allows to be able to
see aphrodite sticks her with a spear so
there's a lot of interaction going on
there we could talk about that sort of
stuff all day and examples but
these are all connected with each other
and so this is some i think useful stage
setting
as we move forward with the rest of this
very interesting subsection in which
we're going to be talking about epic
tragedy
comedy and some other key things like
necessity
individuality
and how we understand the gods in
relation to human beings
you